so they are trying to get back to to
where they were hopefully that's the
plan it's time to dissect all of the
most difficult umbrella academy scenes
to film including but not limited to
cornfield explosions amputations and
seven hours of blood curdling screams
definitely take some discipline take
some hard work number one the stars of
this show tend to put their vocal cords
through the ringer when filming intense
scenes in this example we're talking
about aiden gallagher who plays five
having to chop his literal arm off
five's arm needs to get cut off but he
needs to survive it so we had to figure
out a way of like him applying a
tourniquet with one hand aiden lost his
voice multiple times when filming this
scene and then again in post-production
while doing recording replacement
dialogue i blew my voice out quite a
couple of times shooting that and also
an adr number two
you'd be surprised to learn that one of
the most difficult things to shoot in
season three was running on a treadmill
tom hopper who plays luther had a less
than great time getting into character
on those things we look like we're old
men on like we've just broken our legs
and we're just getting back into rehab
and to make matters worse and actually
when we had to do these tighter shots we
had to pretend to run number three
this was by far one of the cast's least
favorite scenes to film it makes sense
why it would be shot at the very end
that was a very painful day we all had
to stare up into these bright lights and
scream for pretty much seven hours
straight some of the actors who didn't
have to do the scene expressed just how
grateful they were to be left out
i have to say i felt very fortunate that
i was dead yeah some of them also
expressed concern for their fellow
co-stars
i was worried for a few of you a couple
times
because like everyone would start to go
like blue in the face number four
sometimes the outfit you've gotta wear
to work can make or break your entire
day especially if the entire thing is
made out of leather and doesn't bend at
the joints the cast of umbrella academy
had a super difficult time performing in
these tight leather jumpsuits oh it was
so tight no screaming
just leather not comfy didn't uh bend in
the knees or in the joints number five
okay obviously we loved watching this
dance-off play out but some of the less
coordinated cast had quite a difficult
time getting it down so who's the best
dancer on the crew
definitely not this guy
according to elliot the dance came a bit
more naturally for emmy raver lampman
and david castaneda but for him and the
rest of the crew rehearsal days were
much longer jake epstein shares how they
even studied kevin bacon's moves for a
little assistance they're like get get
kevin bacon get the screen
so we'd like watch him and then try to
imitate it number six who could forget
this iconic season two moment in the
third episode of the season we get to
see a great example of anya's powers as
an entire cornfield is blown to bits fun
fact all of that corn was grown
specifically for that scene the thing
that made it so difficult to shoot was
just how unpredictable growing crops can
be in an interview with slash films the
director steven sergic talks about how
stressed he was when visiting the
cornfields three weeks before shooting
and the corn had just barely started
growing i was sick he said i didn't
think it was going to be ready but
luckily farming specialists stepped in
and planted genetically manipulated
seeds three weeks later the corn was
much larger than they ever expected and
they had to re-light the entire scene
surgic told comic beets i was thinking
the corn is going to get up to three and
a half four feet like very tall grass
no we go there and it was eight and nine
feet it was insane it was so high that
it was dark inside when you walked
through the rows
number seven interestingly enough aidan
gallagher's most difficult scene was the
first scene he ever shot for the pilot
no not because of a wardrobe malfunction
or losing his voice a dozen times but
because he was so nervous when i jumped
forward and got stuck in the future
do you know what i found no
nothing in an interview with looper
aiden discussed the scene where five
talks to vanya about the end of the
world as an actor the first day of any
production is the most stressful it's
the test to figure out and see if the
chemistry works between the characters
and you can feel out what direction
everybody is going in well in our
personal opinion we'd say the chemistry
is very apparent great job aiden number
eight we've got a lot going on in this
season 2 episode when 5 arrives in the
1960s he sees his siblings fighting
soviet soldiers right before a massive
nuclear blast hits the streets this
scene was actually supposed to be shot
in one take but due to how dangerous it
ended up being they couldn't even film
it on the street there were a ton of
logistical issues while attempting to
bring this sequence to life in an
interview with before and afters everett
burrell the visual effects supervisor
explains we couldn't control the street
for four or five days or two weeks solid
to build and prep so instead we built a
360 degree blue screen on our back lot
in toronto we called it the blue screen
playground he also shared the sequence
was one of the hardest most complicated
things i've ever done
number nine the action-packed and highly
entertaining fight scene between hazel
and cha-cha might look effortless but it
actually took months of training i think
they'll be surprised
uh to see us
doing hand-to-hand combat
and shooting guns cameron britton who
plays hazel shared in an interview with
inverse some fun facts about working
with mary j blige with mary we trained
for a couple of days before we went in
and shot it and she had been training at
six in the morning almost every day for
months she came ready to fight cameron
really took a liking to fight scenes
especially one in particular that he
says was the most difficult one to date
number 10 diego is definitely a force to
be reckoned with even for a seasoned
fighter like hazel in his interview with
inverse cameron gives us a bit of
insight into what it was like to film
that scene with david castaneda david is
so fast that my reactions are just
trying to keep up with him he explained
how he was essentially just there for
david to unload a barrage of punches
why are you here
well
yeah go stop number eleven at the end of
season two
there is a major face-off with the
commission's agent on a farm but
something you may not know is that there
was a major setback due to the weather
conditions in his interview with before
and afters everett burrell shares some
insight on this snowy debacle half the
scene was shot out on normal grass out
in the field and then it snowed and it
never stopped snowing so for half the
scene we had to roto-half the actors out
and put in grass and then the other half
of the scene we had to do the opposite
we had to put snow in for the reverse
shots would you have ever guessed the
snow wasn't part of the plan number 12.
a fun fact we learned is that elliott
paige learned to play the violin
specifically for the show in an
interview with pop buzz elliott shared
that he can play a slightly decent
twinkle twinkle little star but that's
about it he even had to have a teacher
on set who he says was very patient with
him apparently though even with
elliott's twinkle twinkle little star
knowledge he still had to have a
stand-in for the more complicated violin
scenes his stand-in was a 16 year old
prodigy named imogen sloss
the umbrella academy will never stop
impressing us with complicated intense
and beautiful sequences it's clear how
much heart and hard work goes into
creating each season what were you most
surprised to find out about the show
you